we now set out to study the Poisson
process which is a continuous time
version of the Bernoulli process in the
Bernoulli process time is divided into
slots and during each one of the slots
we may either have an arrival or no
arrival in the Poisson process time is
continuous and we may get arrivals at
any time we want to define the Poisson
process by introducing some assumptions
that in some way is parallel the
assumptions that we made for the
Bernoulli process
what were those assumptions the first
one we made was the assumption of
Independence namely that what happens in
different slots are independent
similarly for the Poisson process we
will make the following independence
assumption if we consider two intervals
two time intervals that are disjoint and
look at the random variable that stands
for the number of arrivals during this
interval and that interval we will
assume that these two random variables
are independent but even more than that
if we take any collection of disjoint
time intervals and we look at the
Associated random variables the
Associated numbers of arrivals that
collection will also consist of
independent random variables the second
assumption for the Bernoulli process was
one of time homogeneity namely at each
slot we had the same probability of an
arrival we want to make a similar
assumption for the Poisson process and
it's going to be the following the
probability that we have K arrivals
during an interval of a certain duration
tau is going to be the same no matter
where that interval sets so if this is
an interval that has a certain duration
and this is an interval that has the
same duration the probability of three
arrivals in this interval is going to be
the same as the probability of three
arrivals in that interval and therefore
since this probability does not depend
on where the interval sets that
probability will be fully defined by the
number of arrivals that were interested
in and the length of the interval as
opposed to the location of the interval
so we will be using this notation here
to indicate this probability in this
notation we think of Tao as a constant
and then P of K corresponds to
probabilities in particular if you add
over all case the various probabilities
what you should get would be a value of
1 because this exhausts all the
possibilities and K here ranges from 0
to infinity because we allow an
arbitrarily large number of arrivals
during a given time interval now with
this assumption in place it would still
be possible to have arrivals that happen
simultaneously multiple arrivals at the
same time point in order to avoid this
situation we introduce one more
assumption which is the following it
talks about the number of arrivals
during a time interval that has a small
length Delta during a small time
interval there is negligible probability
of having more than one arrival we will
either have 1 or 0 arrivals and the
probability of one arrival is a certain
number lambda times Delta it's
proportional to Delta so if the interval
becomes smaller and smaller that
probability also goes to 0 but it goes
to 0 at a rate proportional to Delta so
you can think of lambda as probability
per unit time these are the units of
lambda now here I'm writing an
approximate equality what does that mean
it means that these are not exact
expressions but they are exact within a
second order term and the second order
term is a term that's negligible
compared to the first order term when
Delta is small more precisely
mathematically what we mean is that a
second order term compared to a first
order term goes to 0 as Delta goes to 0
finally let me reiterate that lambda
should be interpreted as an arrival rate
it is a probability per unit time the
bigger lambda is the bigger the
probability is that we get an arrival
during a small time interval if we
double lambda then we double the
probability that we have an arrival
during a small time interval and so we
expect to have about twice as many
rivals
hence the interpretation is an arrival
rate we will see shortly that this is
also justified because lambda shows up
in expressions for the expected number
of arrivals during a time interval